i have a feeling you're both hearing a
lot about this but i'm full-blown
obsessed with socks i don't care if you
use all of my time today talking about
this but i want the full oral history on
socks how'd the idea come to be and how
did the character evolve from like
original inception to what we see in the
finnish film
okay well uh
at the beginning uh
of
developing the movie i was working with
uh matt
who was our first writer who left the
project
amicably just he had other things to do
uh he um
and i were thinking about a cute thing
we needed a cute thing for the movie and
we did a research into what cute things
were good what cute things were bad and
the cute thing was
something that was like loyal to our
hero and was not snarky and was always
was funny but not in a
sarcastic or cynical way
and
looking at the way r2d2 and his limited
movement was always appealing to us so
we had first thought um
a
like a monkey because of the space
program like that there would be this
monkey set in space and that would be
that kind of thing but then like a
helper monkey but it wasn't quite as
funny as cat movement robotic cat
movement was funnier and i just we
always think thought of like oh cat on a
computer is funny so
if we can get cat on a computer we'll do
that and then so we combining a lot of
the kind of animatronic sensibilities
with
uh this
kind of helper cat
um instead of a helper monkey uh became
socks and i so yeah that was just one of
the earlier things
there were two big things that that um
matt had done uh that and the sandwiches
was a riff that he and i did so he and i
were both like the cat and sandwiches um
so
yeah so then we we peterson was who we
thought would be great for the role we
had him
as our temporary voice
and
he was always meant to be this thing
where buzz was going to be isolated from
society we have that first and so the
cat was going to be his one uh
constant through time but there used to
be this whole thing where
uh
he would like hey you wanna
you wanna watch uh tv uh or you wanna go
to a party he kept like trying to like
throw him yeah thank them like hey this
uh might be socialized get him
socialized yeah
yeah
there was this great bed bath beyond
joke we had to cut which is an amazing
sentence to say
he's like uh
you know where he's like saying you know
buzz has been gone so long that there's
like
like a mountain of bed bath beyond
coupons like behind his door
and uh and then they can't say you know
that they 30 you know even if they're
expired they'll still take them uh which
i i quite i was sad to lose that joke uh
but uh yeah so that was that was the
that was the
that's the beginning of socks i am a
very big believer that you just
delivered one of the best characters
like ever in a pixar movie and given how
high their standards already are that is
really something else this is a little
bit of an obnoxious question about that
though but given the fact that light
year exists within the reality of toy
story was there ever a concern that
socks was like so damn cute that it
would seem strange that socks toys
didn't exist in andy's world no no
because um
because
buzz the buzz toy is from
you know it's from like i imagine like a
cartoon and i don't know if socks is in
that cartoon like they may have like
let's do you know now now buzz with
something else made the cartoon without
socks yeah
[Music]
yeah no they would have been like we're
gonna too much to animate yeah they're
gonna they're gonna go well actually or
it could have been like fantastic four
where it's like we can't put johnny
torch johnny human torch in there we'll
put herbie the robot you know they would
they would mix up the the
load out there for the for that thing
but no um there was originally when we
first pitched socks to andrew he's like
but there was no cat we didn't have a
cat and he didn't have a cat in the
movie i mean toy story i'm like we had
to like yeah but it could be great and
also like who knows what andy has the
entire line of toys like that's a lot
that's why the next thing should be toy
story like 1.5 and it's about a
different kid in another house where
instead of buzz they have a socks yeah
yeah that's funny wow i could go on and
on about this yeah look at that yeah
yeah
speaking of that particular world like
andy's reality in andy's reality was
light year the movie also created by
pixar like does pixar exist within a
pixar movie we found out today that yes
it does
but i didn't understand we didn't no
it's it's simple because the title
because pixar it says pixar in the title
of our movie right that means pixar
exists in andy's world
right and at the end of the movie but we
somehow were no we're characters in the
movie
so now if you think about it
now we're like disney characters that we
made the movie
in universe
okay
someone's like what was the name of the
of the filmmaker
and we were like i don't know i made up
some nonsense and then um and then he's
like no because your name is in the
credits so you you know basically they
figured out that we that we
existed that's weird i love that
technically every single person involved
in making this movie is now a pixar
character and that thrills me
it probably has some legal implications
we don't want to investigate but that's
fine yeah
i have to ask you about uh casting chris
too because it even mentioned captain
america in the notes in terms of that
character also being a hero out of time
so how much did his performance as
captain america really influence your
decision to cast him in this iconic role
well it was uh was
his ability to do the kind of
heroic uh
uh superhero character and also do
comedy at the same time but uh we we
discovered today when someone had a
similar question that we it was the
movie snow piercer that actually both of
us that sold both of us on christmas
right and it was it's so random but as
far as the discover that five and a half
years later
yeah right but the depth of his
performance in that movie was like oh i
see yeah he's he could he
we could do a superhero or a heroic
character who has a
pretty big interesting flaws yeah who
has a deep seated guilt and a conscience
right yeah we need a guilt i never
thought i'd be connecting snow piercer
with a pixar movie but this all makes
total sense to me
i wanted to talk a little bit about your
histories with pixar so galen first for
you is there anything that like 1995 you
first working on the first toy story
movie that you know
would never imagine something that you
managed to accomplish on light year
would ever be possible whether it's a
tech thing a story development anything
at all okay well first of all all of it
but but like backing up for a second
when we did toy story
no film had been done
on computers before right like the whole
concept was totally new and i didn't
actually understand what we were doing i
didn't understand it to the until i got
into a theater with normal people and
watched it went oh wait a second it's a
movie like i really we were making
graphic images i didn't get that we were
making a movie
so i could never have conceived of this
from that perspective in and of itself
um but also the
the technology
is
i mean think about it right the the
iphone is
more powerful than the computers we used
to create toy story like things have
changed
radically in the last 30 years it's
pretty phenomenal wow
like that that is incredible yeah i was
just having that dilemma with my iphone
that could now shoot 4k versus paying
all this money on like a different
camera to shoot videos it's not
necessary anymore it's wild there you go
all right so for you now this is your
very first time solo directing pixar
feature film so even with all your
experience working on pixar films in
other capacities was there anything
about you know being the soul helmer on
one of these films that you know caught
you by surprise and maybe required a bit
of a learning curve
well i i look at it with the way i look
at it is i would have
i would have i'm so glad i got to do
everything i did before this movie and i
i
everything that i learned leading up
into this film i utilized on the film
um
there weren't a lot of surprises
just because i'd been so close to the
process
uh but it really was what was surprising
to me was like oh i don't know what
experience i wouldn't have wanted to
have had to make the movie
and so i think that the benefits of
everything that i've learned allowed me
to maximize
what we needed to get
up on screen so
that's the way i think about it
it's quite the evolutions part of the
reason why i admire pixar so much
because sticking with the same talent
and fostering them and giving them a
thorough understanding of every
department i think makes all the
difference yeah yeah thank you very much
thank you